thank you navier for the introduction
hello everyone it's great to have you
all here with us in this session we will
discuss the unique
uh omics logic project based training
program which is introduction to big
data bioinformatics as you can see on
the screen this is a special fall
program to make bioinformatics
accessible to students and researchers
to learn about cutting edge formics
research bioinformatics and
computational biology
and we will learn to analyze complex
data sets to answer important research
questions
so in the next
few slides we will learn more about the
topics resources and the outcomes
associated with this one month training
program and i hope that i'm audible uh
to all of you
and uh
if you have any
thank you dr krith and if you have any
questions throughout the presentation
feel free to put it in the chat and
i hope that once that as an aznavi i
have showed you all we have logged into
the topper to the
learn or mix logic portal which we will
be using throughout the presentation
so
this research based training is
scheduled to start on 24th september
2021
and the live with a live orientation
session that we will be going through in
much more detail uh in a while
the advantage of learning something new
is that we all start from
the beginning right
so with this incredible growth in big
data
with this incredible growth big data has
turned out to be a remarkable career
choice for many today industries from
various domains offer different
positions for big data professionals
that includes biology and healthcare too
so uh
from a data perspective
what makes uh biology unique from other
realm
is its sheer size
for example typical genome of a microbe
which might have a 40 000 gene
if we assume that there are
1000 distinct variations or variants of
each gene that would require us to
conduct one billion tests so just
imagine the amount of information that
could be generated from this sort of
analysis so biology in reality is
rapidly acquiring the characteristics of
data science
and
billions of data points on genes
proteins and other molecules are
compiled in large files and are
systematically studied so analyzing this
data will lead to more knowledge and
understanding about living organisms
including human health biotechnology
crops and livestocks so it includes a
lot of application in that context
so this course will give an overview of
bioinformatics for students biologists
clinicians so the influx of data
associated with methodologies and
data-driven research making this biology
bioinformatics for life science as one
of the prominent and
emerging technology that one could
start learning about so it would involve
learning about computational method and
it will involve learning about
the biology and the biological research
associated with it to give you an
overview
i would wanted to
let you given a basic understanding of
ngs based techniques and its translation
application because it's one of the key
research areas in today's world so ngs
is
beginning to provide these powerful
insights into genetic mutation
molecular networks underlying diseases
for a broad set of genes so let me ask
you a simple question
uh
what is uh what is ngs techniques and uh
please feel free to write it in the chat
box
your answers
so i'm just asking like what is ngs
can you can you tell us
sequencing technology vanessa thank you
for answering
sarah says illumina
okay illumina is a sequencing company
nupur is saying next generation
sequencing technology
all right
yeah next generation sequencing
so next generation sequencing or ngs uh
that's the full form for next generation
sequencing or high structure sequencing
is a massively parallel sequencing
technology that offers
ultra high throughput scalability
and speed
so the technology is used to determine
the order of nucleotides in
entire genomes
or targeted regions of dna or rna
i hope that clarifies uh doubts if you
have any
so
the next question
i would wanted to ask you all is
what is the role of
bioinformatics in ngs
why we use bioinformatics for ngs
lisa yeah tools to investigate genomic
questions that's a good answer
anyone else data interpretation
george thank you
so we are discussing here about a
program which is
on big data bioinformatics
and
we are talking about big data and
data becomes big and big in size when we
when the data have few characteristics
so
we define big data by few
characteristics and
it's good to see you all answering
different aspects such as noku here is
saying to study different data sets of
genes yeah in a way yes
so next generation sequencing
technologies
offer high throughput
rapid and accurate methods
for determining the precise order of
nucleotides in a given
within a dna rna molecule right that's
what i said so the combination combined
the combined power of ngs and
bioinformatics
kind of play vital role for different
applications
it plays vital role for diagnostics that
has been proven
it plays role in medical treatment and
epidemiological research
ngs technologies are currently used for
whole genome sequencing that many of you
have heard of
and it helps in
investigation of genome diversity as
lisa said
and also there are other applications
which are very
new are getting much more popular
because of its
vast in you know
integration ability or that data
interpretation ability as george said so
there are different fields such as
metagenomics epigenetics
then discovery and discovering
non-coding rnas
protein binding sites
and then the gene expression profiling
which is the rna-seq
so what we did learned
a little bit is that
why we should learn and understand and
analyze high throughput data what is the
need and why we should be doing it and
why should we be learning about it
we need to do that because big data now
has application in almost all the
technologies right and it's equally
important to learn this aspect in terms
of biology in terms of in terms of life
sciences
so now
like as we had an overview of what we
are doing and i wanted to tell you just
about like the omics logic program or
this training so omix logic is a program
that embeds data driven concepts
into biological projects so it's a
project driven training
so we will be all the time describing
examples taken from publications
examples taken from
ncbi data sets
so
spanning the student learning journey
from
an observer to participate in research
so when we talk about training we
usually think about delivery lectures
and sessions and sometimes we also have
opportunity to do some hands-on here is
the opportunity to to do research and
that's why it is a project research
based training so this journey begins
with identifying a interesting
biological research question
or the a question that can be answered
with data because in bioinformatics
we kind of look for data-driven uh
data-driven approaches and not in
bioinformatics if we talk about data
science machine learning those are all
data driven approaches right
so the journey begins with identifying
question or a research problem and then
we collect data we organize data and we
understand
by analyzing that
and drawing conclusion from it right and
this journey could start from
uh from the just from the login on the
learn portal i mean it's as simple as
that so all of you if you haven't done
so far please make sure that you create
a login because with so much data
available on biological topics and
questions learning about this exciting
feed and application is a pathway to new
research and opportunities so please
i'll make sure that you have a login on
the learn omixlogic so this omixlogic
curriculum uh actually it follows as i
said project based student centric
learning model where our focus is to
simplify complex bioinformatics methods
and use this method
efficiently and find meaningful
information to tackle the unsolved
problems in biology and healthcare and
i'm telling you it's pretty exciting
so this online pro program is actually
as navia said is designed for everyone
including students and participants who
do not have a background in
bioinformatics and are biologists or
clinicians who wants to learn about big
data uh high throughput data engineers
data analysis processing section uh we
will be covering in this program
genomics as i said transcriptomics and
biomedical data science and machine
learning so looking biology uh the big
data in biology and
being able to gain insight so
so it has several applications from
research to discovery and to integration
of you know system biology so as as a
result of this the participant will have
an opportunity to become more proficient
in the analysis interpretation of
various types of omics data read through
publications understand publications and
the
different type of research that is being
conducted so it includes statistics and
machine learning
so let's begin with the review of topics
and again i wanted to insist that if you
have any questions
please feel free to put it in the chat
box
so as i was saying that let's review the
topics that we will discuss in depth so
during this one month training
we will cover important topics that are
used by the biomedical and biotechnology
industry the 21st century uh problems so
that would include uh introduction to
big data and biology then we will do
introduction to genomics mapping and
sequence visualization big data
obviously and then introduction to
transcriptomic gene expression data
analysis then we will learn about
differential gene expression then we
will learn about biomedical data science
that would involve learning python and r
for data analysis not like a program not
as a programming language but for
as a tool
and then the application of this into a
real machine learning uh project ngs
based project so these are some of the
key topics that we will be covered and
let me now go into much more detail so
that you get a clear understanding of
how this program will be
and what are the resources that will be
and how to utilize that with a you know
with best approaches and best ways
so in the first session and the first
week of this training starting 24th uh
24th september 2021 we will have
introduction and commencement of the
program then we will have introduction
of the faculty mentors and trainers then
we will demonstrate you the slack
channel so there's a slack channel
associated with each of these programs
where we have all the participants
together so that we can communicate
about the resources
the meeting links and all of that like
any sort of questions uh technical
questions that you have and we will have
also mentors added to the slack channel
so that they can answer to your
questions and then there is a program
page so the program page where you get
all the schedule all the
other resources we will showcase you
that in a while so in this session we
will be overviewing
taking an overview of the resources and
it's kind of an orientation session
where you will be getting the passwords
and the access to the platform such as
the learn platform and the tbi info
platform then there will be a q a
discussion where you can ask your
questions similar to this session and
what are the expectations schedule and
review of the training program
description of the structure of the
course and deadlines so that is
something that we will be discussing on
the first session um making everything
everyone uh having all the resources
connecting
for collaborative work
so uh we have been discussing about the
platforms so
one of the
uh platforms that we will be utilizing
and it is something of
of a core of what we do is utilize this
t-band platform along with open source
resources so the team info platform was
developed at the top of mindfulness
business center by computer scientists
and mathematicians passionate about big
data integration so to make the power of
advanced algorithms accessible
the system
allows for a user-friendly and logical
data analysis interface
that can be used by anyone
so with biological discovery in your
mind
and a focus on advanced methods like
mathematical modeling machine learning
and efficient computational tools this
pro this platform can actually take you
further in
in a very short amount of time
so there are several sections that we
will be utilizing in this program itself
which includes the transfer atomics gene
expression data analysis section the
data mining section on machine learning
and utilizing different network analysis
and then you will be able to see
and manage your own pipelines and see
what kind of analysis that you have run
so the resources and the data i mean
tells us a clear story
so that as a scientist as a researcher
as a student anyone is capable of
becoming scientist now and has the
opportunity to do the research by
so this growth in data has allowed has
allowed researchers to sequence
individual genomes and match
combinations of mutations with specific
diseases i'll give you an example of
cancer
as cancer is inherited inherently a
disease of the genome it is not
surprising to see ngs technology already
becoming applied to cancer research with
promises of greater understanding of
carcinogenesis right so while the task
of disappearing the cancer genome code
is still ongoing we are already
beginning to see the application of
genetic based testing or diagnostics or
biomarkers in the in the area of cancer
so this program or this course is
designed to highlight the role of big
omics data
that is shaping modern biomedical
innovation where molecular data is used
for precision diagnostics big data
integration and machine learning is
transforming personalization of
treatment selection and innovative
algorithms allow for unprecedented
capabilities
for drug discovery designing even of
large molecules and drug repurposing
this we
i mean this is the first week that we
are describing in this week after
learning about the introduction to
bioinformatics and bison the molecule
we will learn about the topics of
genomics topics in genomics so what we
will cover is genomic variation which
will be a detailed understanding the
types of different sequencing methods
targeting targeted sequencing whole
genome sequencing uh whole exam
sequencing and then we will understand
about the logical steps for genomic data
analysis and what are the associated
algorithms then we will look uh
anna analyze the results by visualizing
using the integrated
or integrative genomic viewer
so genomics as i said is a very
important is an essential subfield of
bioinformatics and a major force in
expanding human knowledge
of genetic
of genetically associated or
associations with diseases and other
traits
so it is an interdisciplinary field
which includes the development of
methods for dna sequencing as well as
for big data analysis of genomic
sequences right
so there are massive databases and as as
i was telling you that where the
opportunity lies and that opportunity
lies in these massive databases of
biological sequence data such as gene
genbank embl sra that allows for
data-driven research and knowledge
discovery so uh
once the sequence or the raw data is
available it is
required or you need to process it to
get an interpret biological insights
right so we will be using defined
logical steps that are applied to
process the genomic data associated with
various algorithms such as
bow tie 2 or here this is an example of
trelka
and to explore the genomic data we would
then visualize it with integrated
integrative genomic viewer to get a
detailed view of the
single nucleotide polymorphism or the
snp
so in this first week we will learn
about various algorithms that are
associated with genomic data analysis on
the tibial platform
and during this week the second
important aspect as i was telling you
the participants will have the
opportunity to complete the online
courses ahead of the session so you you
will have the access once you register
for the course and you will have access
to all of these courses so you can
prepare like take these courses and
prepare ahead so to ask your questions
and which would be more meaningful we
kind of recommend to take the courses
ahead and if not if you have missed a
session for example then you will have
an opportunity to cover all the
important topics that are associated
with the weak learning using this uh you
know resource
there's a link associated with it uh so
you will get an understanding of genetic
associations provided by genomic
research that has a great value in
medicine even in agriculture even in
ecology and biotechnology and many other
industries so as i was telling you you
will find uh out about different topics
relevant to genomics while browsing
through the courses so this is course
three on learn omix logic portal so if
you have already created login you can
check out the resource and you will
check out the online courses which will
be available
for you to take
so the in the next week
after genomics we will start learning
about the important gene expression data
as i was telling you before
so in in this we will learn about the
analysis logic
which is i mean
from raw reads to table of expression
how we do that and what are the common
sources of unwanted technical variations
how do we you know clear
how do we
remove those unwanted technical
variations what are the pre-processing
steps how we can filter and clean the
table of expression how we can load
processing data for analysis so we will
learn about next generation sequencing
transcriptomics to understand the
variation and we will do practical so we
will do hands-on training
uh on data sets so today i mean if you
are all available till the end we will
have a short demo session working with
breast cancer subtypes and your
sequencing data so this project
that we are talking about it uses
uh data from 2016 study by bradford
james at all where they did a whole
transcript from profiling
operation-derived xenographs model
so as a tool to identify both tumor and
stomatal specific biomarkers
so the
pdfs like it's a short form for patient
derived xenograft
what are they i mean you must have this
question if you are not sure about what
is pdx i just said that there's a cancer
subtype and
so what is pdf
so pdx or patient-derived xenographs are
models for cancer in which human tumor
samples are studied in a mouse
environment
so in the study they distinguished tumor
as tomato compartment by associating the
stomatal compartments with murine uh
mouse which is mouse transcriptomic
profiles
so utilizing the transcriptomic sections
on the on the platform we will be
learning about analysis logic as i said
from rory to table of expression
pre-processing steps filtering and
cleaning the table of expression so this
analytical platform the keybind for
platform will provide hands-on
experience for for anyone to learn and
apply
uh data sets and the sections are color
coded with a logical map so explanation
so you define the explanation of methods
detailed input and output formats and
reproducible workflows when you go
through and browse and go through this
courses and training
so in this week obviously as we have it
for genomics we will be working on the
transfer atomic section section and
learn on and use the learner mix logic
where you will have the opportunity to
go through the courses that are put
together and covers important topics
relevant to rna sequencing uh gene
expression data analysis and application
in the next uh session in that week only
where we are going through rnac and we
were like learning about rnac
and uh its application
we will have an opportunity to now
dig deeper and understand the
application in research which is
introduction to differential gene
expression we will learn about uh
techniques or algorithms such as the sec
hr
we will learn about visualization or how
to visualize this data by plotting
volcano plots or heat maps and then we
will be learning about regression and
factor regression analysis that is a
machine learning technique to understand
about the factors and different types of
you know conditions
so this will give you an idea of how
transcriptomics is applied and how it is
so much applied to biomedical research
and different kind of research and it's
uh
how can you do it like with a proper
data set that you can you know work on
so during this advanced analysis of rnac
as i was saying data sets we will be
using two different data sets one that
has already one that you have already
learned about uh which is the patient
xenograft one and then we will be using
the second data step a second data set
uh that will help us understand more
about the application of machine
learning on gene expression data how
different types of data can be
integrated
to get an
outcome or get a holistic understanding
so in theory we will learn about in this
during during this entire week like we
will be learning about basic statistical
techniques uh
tests such as student t test we will be
able to perform statistical differences
between two groups to learn about the
key features
so i think it will be much more clear
during the session because we have a
dedicated session described
for this and obviously the online
resources so everything is also
detailedly described so to understand
advanced visualization interpretation of
output and then do the practical
hands-on training on differential gene
expression using the hr sequencing uh d6
and such tools you should uh
try practicing on the transcriptomic
section for the courses on also on the
p-band for platform which we'll be
covering in the session
so once we have practiced regression and
other statistical techniques
we will progress to more advanced
signals
well these are the techniques that are
changing the way data is being analyzed
and yes i'm talking about machine
learning deep learning and artificial
intelligence so during this week we'll
start learning about data mining and
classification techniques in this
session we will cover introduction to
machine learning types of machine
learning methods overview of supervised
machine learning methods which is which
will be helpful for us in finding
patterns from multi-dimensional omics
data we will be able to find
similarities in the data and to use that
we will use algorithms such as principal
component analysis and clustering such
as hierarchical and k-mean clustering so
giving you an example i mean finding
relationship is in data is pretty
important let's say we have we collected
data on uh for example here we have data
on eye color gender age
height and weight of people these are
all clinically important data right we
hypothesize that some variables here are
related and some are not
we also think that there are exceptions
to the rules the age and height or
weight are related but not always right
so relationships observed in data can
show
which variables are related which
variables are not related
for example weight and height seems to
be logically related
are they in the data set
if we plot a trend line here like you
can see on the screen
if we plot a trend line we will find
that the trend line goes up
the higher the higher the weight the
higher the height weight also increases
but the dots are not too close to the
line some dot seems to be far away far
away from it right is there a way to
quantify this relationship that we found
so
in this session in this machine learning
session we will be understanding of
other analytical methods for processing
visualization and analysis of complex
biomedical data we will be learning we
will be learning about the terminologies
that are very common and very important
for machine learning and artificial
intelligence in biomedical discovery and
we will be utilizing the t bind for
platform uh where we have the data
mining section to you to do the
statistical analysis and apply ml
algorithms so you will find this all
information in
uh course number seven obviously
associated with the session
and once we have got an understanding of
how this application is how we can use
different types of machine learning and
do data mining next is to do you know
predictive modeling or on applying
supervised machine learning methods so
in this session the last session or the
sixth session we will be learning about
decision trees random forest support
vector machine and then project examples
so in the project example we will also
take you through what would be the next
step once you have done this learning
once you have done
all of this session
what can you do next you can work on
your own project where we have the
research fellowship program to support
development of project
and we have a lot of project examples
that we will be uh that you will have
you'll be having access to to develop a
specialization so if you're interested
in infectious diseases whether you're
interested in cancer or whether you're
interested in malaria or you have any
other disease in your
in or any other problem in your uh
for you to do research so we have
already a compilation of all of this and
as i promised earlier uh i will be
taking you to the
way we can do like you can access all of
these resources register for the pro
program but before that i'd like i would
love to uh invite
dr harpreet to give you a short
demonstration of one of the projects